hey guys Pete here I was doing some
research that led me back to the prince
that was promised theory so I thought
I'd make a video about it the show
hasn't deviated much from the books in
regards to the prophecy itself other
than cutting out an important reference
to it in season two when Danny is in the
house of undying during season six it
did reference the prophecy in a marine
team though that isn't from the books
and there was a somewhat heavy-handed
reference in the Tower of joy scene too
so it certainly hasn't been cut
completely out first time we hear about
the prince that was promised in the
books is on that trip through the house
of undying when Danny sees her brother
Rhaegar with his wife Elia Martell and
their newborn son
Aegon he tells her he is the prince that
was promised and his is the Song of Ice
and Fire
Rhaegar had once thought he might be the
prince that was promised as did maester
aemon but later decided that it would be
his son the Targaryen believe that the
prince would be born of their line
because Rhaegar is grandfather Jo Harris
the second had visited a woods witch
that told him that it would be that way
Joe Harris had his two children Rey Ella
and Harris Danny's parents Wed because
the witch told him that the prince would
come from their line it isn't known
where the prophecy started as there
isn't much information about it that we
can draw from based on the fact that
maester aemon mentions a thousand years
- Samwell it should be safe to say that
that the prophecy is at least that old
according to Melisandre the prince that
was promised coming was prophesized over
five thousand years ago but she doesn't
make any mention of who made the actual
prophecy Melisandre sort of uses the
prince that was promised an azure 'hi
interchangeably but we hear her talk
abbas or hai far more often on the other
hand Amon never mentions the name Azure
high when he's talking about the prince
that was promised there are a lot of
similarities in both prophecies though
and there are a couple of references
where they overlap both involve maester
aemon one time he asked Melisandre about
the prince that was promised in relation
to the war for the dawn and another time
he tells Samwell that the prince would
be born of salt and smoke which is the
same thing Melisandre says about his or
hot many of the theories that are based
about Zora hai and the prince that are
promised being different are also
related to maester aemon
he doesn't use the name azure high when
he talks about Daenerys being the prince
that was promised but he's very
where that these or I prophecy exists we
know this because he left a Jade
compendium for John to read which tells
of the story of azor Ahai and his sword
Lightbringer one big difference is that
you never really hear people talking
about the prince that was promised
wielding a sword like Zora hai in that
prophecy but there is a reference to
Rhaegar deciding to become a knight
after he read something in his Scrolls
meaning that he may have uncovered
something to the effect that he needed
to learn to handle sword to fulfill the
prophecy we also learned that the prince
part isn't exactly right Amon tells Sam
that high Valyrian is a gender-neutral
language and the Dragons are neither
male or female this meant that everyone
was misled thinking it was a prince for
over a thousand years here are the signs
of the coming of the prince that was
promised the birth of a prince this
could be wrong since maester aemon says
that it could be prince or princess
based on high Valyrian being
gender-neutral the princes of the blood
of the dragon the woods which would say
that it's specifically the blood that
comes from eros in reality for damn it
smoke
born amid salt ibly ting star in the
skies which has also been mentioned like
being born beneath the bleeding star
there's also the possibility of the
return of Dragons this comes from the
duncan egg stories when he was a boy egg
recalled that King Aerys the first read
about the return of dragons in a
prophecy Amon and Melisandre gave us
most of the information about the
prophecy and they both have different
ideas about who fulfills it when he was
young Amon thought it was that it was
Rhaegar and possibly then his son
Aegon until he was killed during the
sack of King's Landing later once an mo
tells him about the Narus and her
dragons he immediately thinks it's her
Melisandre thinks it's Stannis until he
dies in the show and then says it's John
after he you know he comes back to life
for contrast these are the signs Ozora
hai is reborn after a long summer when
the stars bleed and the cold breath of
darkness falls heavy on the world or
when the red star bleeds and the
darkness gathers he shall be born again
amidst smoke and salt
he shall wake the Dragons out of stone
he shall draw from the fire a burning
sword which is light bringer so there
are a bunch of similarities here the
burning sword is the major difference
and it
makes you wonder how they aren't just a
variation of the same story after all
prophecy is like that if the story has
been passed around for centuries it
would likely change as different
cultures adopted it and made it their
own
the Great Flood myth is a good example
of this in the real world most people in
Western culture grew up learning that
the story about Noah and the Great Archy
built in preparation long before this
story appeared in the Bible it existed
in different cultures with different
details
you know there's Gilgamesh and there's
there's many other different examples
from an objective non-religious
viewpoint you might think that the
Christian faith co-opted this story
because it tells a great story of a
human craving life in the face of
calamity we know details related to the
prince that was promised sound very
Targaryen Rhaegar says that Aegon is the
prince that was promised but then he
adds that there must be another because
the dragon has three heads the names he
gave his children seemed to suggest he
relates this to Aegon the Conqueror and
his two sister wives Rhaenys and Visenya
we don't know exactly why he connects
this to the prophecy but can agree that
this is a Targaryen specific kind of
detail on the other hand Melisandre
mentions the prince that was promised
without the Targaryen references in the
TV show Kim bara tells Tyrion that
Daenerys is the one that was promised
which I assume is just a gender like
gender-neutral way of saying it but
doesn't mention Lightbringer or a dragon
with three heads all of this further
muddies the waters about whether the two
prophecies are from the same original
and have just morphed over time based on
cultures that means we can't deduce if
the prince that was promised in his or
'hi would be the same person if the
prophecy was fulfilled there have been
good theories written for it being the
same person and there have been good
theories written about it being two
separate people at the end of the day
there are only two super-strong
candidates which are Daenerys and Jon
Snow many of the other people that
people you know that you could bring up
just don't really fit the bill
especially the way this you know the
story has developed over all Danny fits
the prince that was promised and also
woke dragons from stones
she doesn't have Lightbringer though and
Jon seems like a much better candidate
to wield an actual sword in battle
against the White Walkers at the same
time he hasn't woken any dragons and his
in possession of the flaming sword so
neither fulfills the aspects of the
azure high version and on top of that we
have
the targeting specific mention of the
dragon having three heads for the prince
that was promised if you watch my
importance of prophecy video you know I
think is likely that the prophecy will
be fulfilled but what is really
important is that each of these
characters stories will be shaped by
decisions they make in relation to it
and the books John is still dead Stannis
is still alive and Daenerys is far
behind her story where she is at you
know in the show I think it's safe to
say that John will be resurrected and
Daenerys will make it to Westeros how we
get there probably won't happen in the
same way as it did in the show but in
the end I think the story is leading to
the same place so until the winds of
winter is released we can't say for sure
how the stories are going to shake out
the question then is can we tell how
these prophecies will shape the end of
the story in the show it's hard to say
in general I would say yes if this does
give us a good idea that there will be a
big war coming it will be a war for the
dawn or a war to beat back the forces of
the others which would like to destroy
humanity I mean this is obvious for a
lot of reasons but we could just go
what's the first thing that we hear
about in the prologue of the books and
the first thing we see in the show is
the Nights Watch coming in contact with
the white Walker from there we can agree
that the Iron Throne isn't what's
important here because the real threat
to everything has been building beyond
the wall right from the very start the
show has accelerated everything to the
point that we will experience the
conclusion of the story pretty soon
regardless of how you feel about how
they've done this we know that the end
they are working towards is based on
what George R Martin told them about how
he envisions the end of the story the
major places they go should be
consistent even though the details on
how they get there are different if the
showrunners know who the prince that was
promised / Ozora hi is I find it
important that they made sure to show
young Ned place the sword dawn at the
foot of the bed where John was born I
mentioned at the beginning that it was
heavy-handed because there's really no
other reason to make this part of the
scene stand out Donna's house Danes
ancestral sword that was forged from a
falling star and also has you know the
falling star right on the hill they set
this up to leave no question that Jon
Snow was born under a bleeding star if
you think there's another reason to add
this part of the scene please let me
know in the comments because I just
can't get around it does that in itself
mean that Jon Snow is Sora hi though
I mean definitely not after all Daenerys
is the one who woke the Dragons out of
stone and she's currently the only one
who's able to ride one of them I'm not a
big fan of the idea that the Dragons
themselves are Lightbringer and I don't
see John waking any other dragons from
stone any time soon so that leaves us
with three possible conclusions one more
will be revealed to make either John or
Daenerys alone fulfill the prop two John
will fulfill one of the prophecies and
Danny will fulfill the other or three
there is only one prophecy which is
fulfilled by both of them together it's
not a question of if one of them is the
prince that was promised and one is
azure high but instead it's that they
are both equally important to fulfill
the prophecy in the end so I don't know
let me know what you think I'm heavily
leaning towards the third option right
now like I said there's a ton of
interesting theories that have been
written for every possible outcome here
but I don't see either candidate taking
the lead like in the race in the show
most theories are based on the books
because there's way more evidence to
draw on but at the end of the day I do
believe that George has told D&D where
to go if not how to get there what
happens in the show matters but can it
help us solve the mystery leave a
comment and tell me what you think is a
Zora hi and the prince that was promised
to different people is it the same
person and you think you know who it is
how would you discount either John or
Danny and say that one is more important
than the other is the prophecy all a
bunch of nothing that was just basically
woven into the story so that we all
waste a bunch of time trying to figure
it out please like the video and
subscribe to my channel I have a
giveaway going on for when I hit 18,000
subscribers I'm giving away a copy of a
night of the Seven Kingdoms which is the
dunk and egg stories and all you have to
do is be a subscriber and leave a
comment some awesome books and make sure
you subscribe now for your chance to win
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon